Jimmy what's up man ain't doing Joey
what's up baby I don't know you look
like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so do you man
[ __ ] [ __ ] come on baby come on
long time man yeah that's timing
[Music]
he's good he's good when I rolled up my
son you had this big old scratch right
here why don't you let me fix this for
you Joey yeah I'm gonna try and hustle a
hustler no no listen I need them
I need $40 men I need $40 okay you know
how it is you know what I'm saying
really this this is what it's come to
for you no listen no man no I got my own
spot I got a junkyard on 45th and Pico
okay I will maybe I'll come back maybe
we'll fix I'm gonna get some I'll fix
this right now for you right now yeah I
need the money Jimmy they ain't gonna
let you do that here what are you
talking about I got my tools in my car
my [ __ ] bat some wax some primer
paint woman it's this right now come on
Jimmy come on Jimmy man all right all
right
[Music]
[Music]
I think those are right hand I know a
heavy bag you just thank me claim to see
Tommy Joey doesn't feed anyone know why
don't you just go clean yourself up and
you can stop by tomorrow
get a excuse for everything you do and
you probably live your whole life like
that finished out what the left
hey Joe you gotta go man come on chill
don't touch me
tonight's my night I know I'm helping no
you're not helping me you're a drunk yes
you're drunk
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no you think you're doing it I fixed
your truck
give me my 40 bucks
Catherine paid you to build me up
Tippett I have to go take care of Tommy
what happened to Tommy
and they make something crystal clear
right now
I'll give us what happened what's
important is what are you gonna do about
it
[Music]
and I let go what I am
I've become what I might be
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you